so
um what i'd like to talk about is using
the wolfram language
to help with astrophotography and other
astronomy-related
uh topics i like to go out in my
backyard and
take pictures of astronomical objects
and
and then sit down late in the evening
and and process
the stuff to get some some decent
looking images
so uh the nice thing about mathematica
is it has all sorts of uh advanced image
processing techniques plus
um uh reams of data which is useful for
astronomical work
and uh and it also has um
interfacing uh features so you can
interface mathematica directly
with your equipment so let's talk a
little bit about some of the uh
the import and export features of
mathematica
um astronomy generates a lot of data
uh at least astrophotography does
and mathematic is great because it can
bring all that stuff
easily into our computational
environment
mathematica has facilities for bringing
in
fitz files these are flexible image
transport system files
which are the uh the preferred media
for um for astronomical data and this is
scientific data plus lots of metadata
which contains information about
the the observation and the equipment
can also bring in conventional images
like jpegs and raw
images and png images
as well as data video data which will be
important for certain types of imaging
and we can import video data directly
into
a notebook as a video object now
so the thing i like to do is to take
astronomical images and there's certain
workflows that you need to
adhere to in order to get a decent image
of what you're looking at astronomical
uh objects are either follow
it seems into one of two classes they're
either
extremely dim and extremely large
or extremely small and extremely bright
and i'm going to talk about
techniques for dealing with both of
these cases
um when we're talking about the dim and
faint objects
uh we're mostly concerned with
eliminating noise
and there's different techniques which
you can implement in mathematica for
dealing with this
and so we're going to talk about
something called calibration which is
the process of taking your images and
reducing noise and increasing the
signal by subtracting out noise which
you can
collect through different techniques you
can align and stack images
and this uses statistical means to
reduce noise because noise by definition
is random
and it will average out increasing the
signal to noise ratio again
you can also stretch an image which
means you can
basically plot a histogram of the
intensities
um of that image and then find the
section that you're interested in and
stretch that out so that
that part of the signal uh encompasses
the full data range
um of your images
and there's other techniques too which
we won't go into
so much uh in this talk uh but we will
in the future
uh like synthesizing images uh uh
in other words creating false color
images uh using uh
color channels that are not necessarily
red green and blue but they may be
narrow band uh channels so you can
emphasize things like
uh the prevalence of a doubly ionized
oxygen
in the nebula and also plotting
spectroscopic data
so let's talk a little bit about image
calibration and
when you take an astronomical image in
the old days
you used to put a big plate on the back
of the telescope
and just give it a long exposure and
this was a tricky thing to do because
the telescope had to be pointing
very accurately for a long period of
time we don't do that anymore
the final image is actually built out of
a bunch of subframes uh there and each
one might be like
a minute long so that reduces the
burden on whatever tracking techniques
you're using
and by adding up a series of these
subframes
you can increase the signal to noise
ratio because the
noise will generally average out
so in addition to these which are called
light frames
you have to take some additional frames
to help with the image calibration and
these frames
don't capture the image but they do
capture the noise
and there's basically three types of
them uh there's something called a dark
frame and uh these are taken
uh the same length as your light frames
um and the camera needs to be the same
temperature as the light frames
but with the camera lens covered or the
telescope lens covered
and uh what this does is it me uh it
measures the amount of
noise generated by the heat of the
electronics inside your camera
and this is a significant uh thing even
regular dslrs do this automatically you
may not realize it
but we take them explicitly to subtract
them out
there's something called a bias frame it
turns out the actual process
of reading out the ccd wells in your
camera
has uncertainty associated with it and
these bias frames which are extremely
short so they don't have any thermal
noise
just contain the uh this offset this
noise associated with
the reed and then there's a third type
of frame called a flat
frame and these are taken um with the
aperture uncovered
uh and pointed at a
neutral evenly illuminated surface
like for instance the morning sky or the
evening sky
and sometimes you you put a cloth over
the telescope to further
even it out and the reason why we do
this is
to measure the light fall off
on on your sensor
large sensors especially those in like
digital slrs
there's noticeable light fall off
towards the edges and you have to be
able to multiply that
out this also uh takes care of
artifacts in your optical train like
dust on the sensor
you'll identify this and that will get
subtracted out
and here is a brief uh
description the raw frame you subtract
out the master bias and the master dark
frames and you divide out by the master
flat and you get a calibrated frame
and then you can take those and you can
stack them to further reduce
noise so let's give an example
of uh this deep sky imaging calibration
workflow so here i imaged m27 the
dumbbell nebula
with a small telescope an agent schmidt
casagrain
and a canon dslr
camera and this was done in my backyard
in downtown urbana
illinois in july
um in this example i i separately
process
the offset and the dark frames
um so i'm importing them you can see
master bias in master dark
and then i form a list of
the light frames these are the actual
exposures
so i'm just bringing in the names of
these frames right now
the reason why i don't immediately bring
the entire set into memory is because
they're extremely large they're high
resolution
and they're in raw format so there's no
compression whatsoever
so each one is probably at least 25
megabytes of data
so um for this example we're just going
to use seven
so i'm going to take seven out of my
list of file names and i'm going to
import them all
okay so now we're going to use the
functional programming features of
mathematica
to take the list of light frames and
subtract off that bias
master bias frame that will take off the
offset and the read noise
and then we're going to take off the
thermal noise by subtracting out the
master dark frame and we're reusing
the list of lights
here so we don't consume additional
memory
and then we're going to use the built-in
image alignment features in mathematica
which are extremely sophisticated
to to bring all the the frames into
perfect alignment because there may be
slight drifting because the telescope
isn't
exactly pointed at the polar axis
and finally we're going to use image
exposure combined to build the final
image
out of the uh collection of calibrated
light frames
and then uh the last thing we do is we
take a histogram
of m27 and we stretch
the interesting data part from about
point one to
point three so it covers the entire data
range and this is what it looks like so
this is the dumbbell nebula
the image is a little noisy uh because
you know we only use seven frames but if
i had
spent a longer period of time the noise
would go down
and the uh interesting
parts of the image would pop up
and finally oh let's go back here if you
have a good eye
you can see that i didn't use any flat
frames in this
example and you can see that the image
is noticeably darker in the corners here
of the image than it is right in the
center and that's that light fall off i
was talking about
because the sensor on the camera is
pretty big compared to
the illumination disc of the telescope
and some people uh fix this with
additional optics to flatten
stuff out uh we're just going to use
software that we have
okay also you can see um artifacts on
the sensor
luckily mathematica has a great function
for doing this
and we're not going to use any of its
sophisticated features here we're just
going to throw the image right into it
and say i do brightness equalize
and and it pretty well flattens out the
image
uh of course it doesn't take care of the
dust artifacts
for that you really need to have flat
frames so
that future examples will have that sort
of
thing
so that's an example of the deep
sky imaging workflow
again a very dim object that
you need to do a lot of noise reduction
to see properly
now we're going to move on to planetary
imaging this is completely the opposite
these are planets tend to be very small
and very bright
compared to nebula and clusters
so you need different imaging techniques
the first thing you need to do is you
need to get
much more magnification so your optical
train
will probably include stuff like barlow
lens or maybe eyepiece
projection and one of the examples here
will be using eyepiece projection
to magnify mars which is
uh notoriously difficult to image
because it's very small
so giving an idea of this difference in
scale
we can compare the size of the moon to
the size of the andromeda galaxy
the moon is about 30
arc minutes in diameter uh even though
it looks big in the sky
it's only half a degree in size for
instance uh
the andromeda galaxy even though it's
much much dimmer
is six times as large
and you can see it with your naked eye
in uh
you know a summer evening you can see it
go out and and just look in the sky and
you can see a little fuzzy patch there
that's not the entire galaxy that's just
the core of the galaxy you're seeing you
need a long exposure to bring out the
full galaxy
so for planetary imaging what we're
going to do is we're going to try to
suck as many
images into the telescope as possible
and
and align them and
stack them all this will
even out the noise and it will also
even out a problem that since we're
using high magnification the image is
probably going to be dancing around a
lot
so the ideal way to bring that sort of
data
into mathematica is with a video clip
the good things about planetary imaging
doesn't require careful alignment of the
telescope because the
alignment technique kind of takes care
of this
so you don't even need to set up your
your
star tracking your closed loop guiding
drift effects
as long as they don't you know are are
terrible
they will be canceled out
you don't need to take a number of
exposures to get a large object like the
andromeda galaxy
you can get it all in one shot noise
isn't much of a problem because
you're stacking many many images
and the equipment is also very modest
this is just a regular webcam that i
modified
to use as an astronomical camera
so i use this very camera here to take
some pictures of mars so
bring in hundreds of images um if you
want you can subtract out a dark frame
uh for each of the images and use our
image morphology
routines determine the centroid of the
circular image or centroid of the planet
and line all the images based on that
centroid
and then you combine the images using
statistical functions
so to show what this can do um we're
going to look at
really horrible data and i i have to
admit that this is not the best image of
mars that you're ever going to see
by the way mars is very close uh next
week or so so i would invite all of you
to go outside around
11 o'clock 12 o'clock and take a look at
it
but so for this one i've imported uh
this
webm video right into mathematica
hopefully everyone will be able to see
it here
so this is this is the product of my my
great efforts
you can see it's just bouncing around
it's it's it's a blob you can't really
tell what it is
you can start to bring up some features
like there's a polar cap there and these
are some of the dark features across the
disk of mars
and that's what i have to work with
which isn't much
but we can get something out of it
so i did go over this couple years ago
so i'm not going to go into it in great
detail the notebook will be available
basically this uh determines what the
centroid of the planet's disk
is and then it moves that into the
center of the image
and then finally it aligns the
all the sub frames in the video from
that centroid and then it does a median
on all of them
so this is here i've imported every
single video frame
from the mars video
and there's probably a few hundred
frames in this
and i call that uh routine which i just
wrote
there and this is the result it's not
great but you can start to bring out
some details
and such and if i had taken the time and
waited until mars was a little bit
higher in the sky
i think we would have got a little
better results and i'm going to try to
do that
maybe tonight or tomorrow to see and
maybe you'll see the results next year
um you can also do this with things that
are not discs like for instance
taking pictures of the moon this is
again which was taken with a webcam and
the eight inch schmidt casa grand
this is a video taken from
my front yard at the moon and it's just
a close-up of one of the lunar craters
uh clavius
so it's just a a webm file captured
on linux using the cheese application
and we bring it right into mathematica
and we take the first frame to be the
key frame and we align
all the images
with the keyframe and i think this is
actually
not even necessary we can just call
image a line on the whole list and it
will just take the first
frame and then i wrote a routine this is
one of the older routines i wrote but it
uses parallel processing to speed things
up
and it it does a median
of the color images and
this is the result this is a close-up of
the crater clavius
these black bars are an artifact of the
stacking routine
but we can crop those out and then the
last thing i like to do
is do a deconvolution on it using our
deconvolution
routines uh with uh and i'm guessing
that the
point spread function is like a five by
five
gaussian matrix and so that sharpened it
up pretty good
and that's just a just a quick webcam
image
of uh clavius there
and you don't even need to have that
sort of sophisticated equipment
um just an iphone held up to the
eyepiece will work in a lot of cases
with a little bit of help from
mathematica this is an image taken
of the sun during the last transit of
venus
there's venus right there here's the
disk of the sun this was taken with a
different telescope with a filter on the
front
but i still used image deconvolution to
sharpen things up
and i did a slight automatic stretching
on the thing
these are sun spots approximately the
size of the earth
and this was taken just after venus
entered the solar disk
at the last transit now let's see when
was that last transit i don't remember
let's see the last transit was
on june 5th of 2012.
and as you can see here venus entered
the solar disk
right around 5 39 p.m central time so
that picture was taken a little bit
later it wasn't seven o'clock but it was
probably closer to six o'clock and
and i took that out at parkland college
and so this sort of data is a good
example of the type of data that
you can get you know just with a natural
language query
right in mathematica
this is another example this is a little
better data here
and it shows what you can do uh this is
um
289 images now this wasn't a video clip
this was just a 289
um small still images taken with a
different
astronomical camera this was a cooled
camera so there's less noise associated
with it
but once i calculated the centroid
and aligned all the images and did a
mild deconvolution
i got a pretty detailed picture of
the cloud structure on jupiter
um so uh what i've been talking to you
up to now
is about um uh basically creating uh
nice pictures of mathematica of
astronomical objects but you can
actually
uh use uh rather modest equipment
and techniques to actually get
interesting scientific data out of
um your amateur astronomy
endeavors and this i talked about this
last year i'm going to
briefly cover it again i won't go into
full detail but this sort of thing can
be used to get
interesting and important data for
instance a light curve of a variable
star
which can give us clues to how far away
it is and its intrinsic brightness
it can also be used to determine uh
things like uh
planetary crossings you can discover
exoplanets using this technique
um so this is a useful uh serious
um astronomical technique and it's not
just limited to
uh professional astronomers a lot of
amateurs uh
like to look for exoplanets and they do
it in a similar way
so the way we extract the light curve is
we have to use mathematica to divide up
the the image
and we use this by by creating kind of a
virtual
uh bullseye here there's where there's
three
interesting areas the center red disc
is where you put the star and then this
blue annulus
measures the the background uh
brightness and you subtract out the
background brightness by counting up
the pixel values and that normalizes the
star brightness to a constant value
and then by taking a series of images
like this
you can get the light curve of the star
as a function of time so obviously we
need to be able to measure
the time so we can
easily create these annular masks using
mathematica's
graphics capabilities and then we
basically count up the
star values after the masks have been
applied
and then using the finding out when the
image was taken
sometimes requires a little more work
than you might think
fitz files tend to have in their
metadata
julian dates and julian dates are ideal
for doing this because they have
it's basically a floating point value
which determines the actual number of
days since january 1st 47 13 bc
in the julian calendar so
we can bring this data into mathematica
and sometimes we have to do a little
extra parsing to get an action
an accurate value and then by using
this photometry function we can get
the brightness as a function of time and
this is a cepheid
example from the university of iowa
there's the cepheid right there and
these are reference stars that
of known brightness that you can
use to get the brightness of the cepheid
as a function of time
so the cepheid is right there and then
by throwing that photometry function
at the series of images with their
intrinsic
uh julian dates we can get
the data we can sort it and start it at
the first julian date
and then plot the the results and this
shows the characteristic
shark tooth form of a cepheid variable
and by doing additional processing on
this you can determine the period of
that and that can be used to determine
the star's intrinsic brightness
and its distance from earth
so finally the last thing i want to talk
about is
actually using mathematica to control
your telescope
and there's a lot of different ways to
do this uh luckily there's
um standard libraries uh for interfacing
to astronomical equipment
like ascom or indy and you can write
interfaces to these things using a
number of different mathematica
technologies
from math link which is now called wstp
dot net link or wolfram's library link
however you don't even need to do that
a lot of these telescope control
protocols are done over a serial line in
mathematic it can just write stuff to a
serial port
so if you know the protocol it's pretty
easy to
control your scope give me an example uh
there's two very popular protocols one's
called the lx 200 protocol
this is supported by meade astrophysics
and lost mandy
another one is called the next star
protocol we're going to talk about
they're similar but not the same
uh we're going to talk about the lx 200
protocol briefly
so we just write some low level
functions here which based on
things like device write and pause
and from character code device read so
this reads
the result from the telescope this
writes the result to the telescope and
this just waits a while for the
telescope to catch up
so if we use the
in the lx 200 protocol the slew command
is this colon ms pound
so we can write that to the telescope
and now we can and also this is the
commands for
uh setting a specific right ascension
and declination target
and then you can then slewing the scope
to a given right ascension declination
is just a matter of parsing these
strings
and then feeding into these low-level
functions that we've written
this is an example here's
m13 which is one of the largest
globular clusters visible in the
northern hemisphere
this is what its image looks like we can
just
open the serial port here it's a usb
tty00 so it's just a
usb port 9600 eight none and one
and feed that device into scope slew to
ra deck
and use the data from star cluster data
to find the coordinates of m13
that will slow your scope right to m13
and then you just close it and the scope
will be pointed there
and you can even take this a step
further
and build an entire with a little
creative carpentry
you can build an entire astronomical
touch screen computer of a raspberry
pi which runs a free version of
mathematica
and you can take images
from this in your scope and mount this
whole thing on your mount
so that's the whole talk
uh does anyone have any questions
and i'm right on time
we'll have about 10 minutes for
questions so you can send
you can chat and i'll try to answer
the stuff as best i can
uh let's see here hold on just like
michael drops has a question
any experience taking bias frames with
the dslr
is a 1 1 000 second exposure good enough
no uh i with bios frames
i always set the camera to it's fast the
shutter speed
so when i take bias frames uh i usually
uh
make them around 1 4 000 of a second if
you have a faster shutter speed
i would recommend doing it at 8 000 of a
second
so that will concentrate just on the
read noise
another question in the path of chat
have you ever tried the aligning and
stacking for landscape astrophotography
uh landscape astrophotography
uh not exactly sure oh landscape
astrophotography oh i know what you're
talking about
uh no that that is okay i know what
you're talking about that's where you
take a long exposure photograph
of the sky and then you illuminate the
landscape with a
like a high-powered flash unit to get
like pictures of trees and stuff
in there i haven't ever tried that
because
uh uh i used to do that many years ago
but but not not anytime recently uh so
that's that's a good thing to try
but um not yet
another question is i think google does
segmentation on sky not sky for that
kind of thing i apologize that wasn't
the question it was a comment
yeah i think i think what you're talking
about is you take a picture
of um a landscape may be partially
illuminated by the sun
and then you subtract out the sky and
then
later on do another image of the sky and
then kind of blend them together
um yeah you can do that i i always
uh see pictures like that and i think
there's a fair amount of manipulation
going on there so
i kind of shy away from that but it
looks great
it looks great uh again the
um you want to get your those are
actually kind of easy to make because
you don't have to worry about
uh precisely tracking an object since
you're taking a picture
of the whole sky and you can take those
sort of pictures without a telescope
just with the camera with a fairly wide
angle lens
as long as you have a tracking mount
that can track the
the sky over you know
10 minutes or so
another question could you establish a
stream to a webcam
and use the signal and mathematica
algorithms to control the microscope
to follow an object like a guidance star
as you name it telescope telescope
um yeah you probably
could um i was um
that requires a very tight uh
feedback loop um i i i use
uh a dedicated guiding software to do
that
and i think uh that might uh
be pushing it uh with mathematica uh the
the i think the the guide the the
guiding corrections
have to be made on a uh on like a one
second or a fraction of a second basis
to get good good exposures and i don't
think we could do that
with the webcam and streaming uh to
mathematica
that's the actual question does the
alignment functionality you're using
uh account for telescope movement and
sky rotation
are all the time scales not long enough
to warrant that
um the um for the video
stacking uh the telescope and sky
rotation don't really matter
because uh as long as your target
remains
in the field of view which is not always
easy because
uh because like with with mars it's a
tiny object
and and the sensor i'm using is a tiny
sensor so
just getting mars onto that sensor is
tricky and if you're not
lined up properly it's going to crawl
off the sensor
after you know a minute or two so you
always have to kind of uh
re-center it but it's this can stay on
there long enough to take
one of these little video clips which
are typically 15 to 30 seconds
uh for long exposure stuff like the
picture of m27
then you do have to very carefully align
the telescope with the polar
axis and you have to
use some sort of guiding so i have a
little scope mounted on top of
my main telescope which locks onto a
star and feeds guiding corrections into
the
mount and with that and also some other
techniques called uh
uh uh periodic error correction
the scope can track for like five
minutes
uh and and get a good subframe that way
and longer than that it's kind of
pushing it unless you do
more fiddly alignment but that's what
you need to get a decent subframe for
a long exposure thing
yes i'm going to share the notebook uh
of the files i will do that
looks like we have a little over two
minutes for any other questions so if
anyone wants to write them in pathable
or
raise their hand in the zoom and we can
allow the the questionnaire to talk
yes if if people want i could set up a
meeting so people can just ask me more
questions
uh if that's uh if that's needed
um we need a package repository for
packaging up all this functionality a
very good question
uh michael i have i i
have a repo with all my astronomical
software
uh that i've written in the wolfram
language in there
including stuff like the image
processing
stuff and the um
the photometry stuff so it's
you can you can check that out and we
can we can
publish that uh and i've been wanting to
do that for a while
would be possible to create a panoramic
shot with this technique and stitch and
thinking of the crater shot sure you can
do that uh you could you could
move the scope around and take quite a
few pictures
and and stitch them together that that
would be very easy to do
and probably easy to do with just a
function call in mathematica because we
have stitching routines
uh i'll have to take a look at that uh
astrophotography with night sight on not
sure what
that is um
fine i can
the next thing i'd like to try out is
get this
this astro computer thing out and point
it at mars maybe in the next couple days
and capture some video right onto that
thing
uh and and that little computer can run
mathematica so i could do all the
processing like
right on the scope so that would be
that'd be an
interesting exercise in uh in
in miniature processing there
yeah sure i i uh these these talks
always turn into blog posts and i've
done a number of them so i think it's
probably time for me to do another one
looks like we have about one minute left
so if there are other questions i just
want to
thank you all for coming and thank you
tom for a fascinating talk
okay very good i'm glad i'm glad that i
i got through it uh
right on time because i was worried that
i had too much stuff
and i wouldn't be able to get to
everything
it was right on the money probably the
best timing i've seen all week
well that's what rehearsal will do for
you there you go
thanks again thank you okay everyone
thank you very much for attending the
talk
um and i hopefully will see you in
person
in the coming years but
right now uh i think things are working
out quite well
enjoy the rest of the conference okay
you too bye guys